is it possible for me to start one
goddamn video without yelling
[Music]
welcome everybody to look wow let's just
jump into it guys on three two one you
didn't jump what the hell man I thought
we were cool oh well the why for those
who don't know is the show where we
review the top 10 culinary experiences
on the Internet
number one Burger King felt sorry for
anyone who asked how broken YouTube's
system is here's that this is now the
top voted meme everybody it's not even a
meme it's a sad the three top voted
memes of all time it's just on YouTube
so I made this for pubes in my tias
wedding please let him see it
thank you I've seen it might say showed
it to me I read it's so amazing I love
that suit that's so cool thank you
sketchy lives that's amazing so cute oh
it didn't even hit me that I was in the
cart the first image that pops up when
you search PETA buying Google it's the
one that in the media keeps using let's
change that 9 year old army finally now
media record can represent me in an
accurate way thank you so much
77 million 14 year olds everybody this
I'm so proud of this community can we
give a shout-out to all women suicide
wait drops to zero percent oh my god
isn't gonna do it every time Oh
oh it needs to change color though it's
not the same satisfaction if it doesn't
change color Peter by shakes hand with
fan whose cousins neighbors stepsister
mailman is a Nazi alright guys it's over
this time hundred-percent guilty I'm
sorry I'm going through it's not funny
alright moving the next target YouTube
gaming in Romania we had news about your
battle versus t-series Thank You Romania
very cool that's very cool of you
Romania
I didn't know Romania had TV remember
the kid who made the Serie subscriber
special and then the ones of guys
special he recently reached 100k and got
a silver blade but again the 9 year old
army get him 2 million subscribers Jane
what an absolute mad lad date what this
is actual channel though I can never
find it it finally came he's already at
200,000 subscribers he did this here is
subscriber special two years ago ok this
guy this guy's been on a grind for a
long time I can respect that
Katie PI helps we want to become the
most disliked video on YouTube YouTube
schedule says a to removing active Sims
beauty pipe ah
to be fair I only lost like 40 K ok I
make that back like that not a problem
next petition for kids to make an
episode of Lu why would sorting by new
so he can see us the unfunny part ok
let's do it let's go through all the
trash free mr. Bies he is in jail this
is what you guys actually have to sift
through
it's pretty cool oh bun gates in my mind
guy thank you egg 2025 subscribe to
Petey pie no hint I haven't got shut it
down
I'll not stand for this what happened to
anti habit I had to pay the loan for my
first suit
shut up crab song petitions her pits to
reflect back to you with the ice why did
I not think of that I have it
hey know deku want a sponsor another
video questions for page when is the
annual bottle flip championship 2018
well it's still 2018 isn't it stop
complaining how did this design came
about I designed it your dumb asses
where is your sign I don't know why are
you afraid of Muppet cuz if getting
Muppets Christmas story
it's a goddamn most terrifying movie
I've seen in my life
let's goddamn ghost in the Attic when
Felix can't upload I lost two teasers
video because people keep subscribing
suffering now I know how he feels like
we had this video that was ready to go
up because it looked like t-series is
gonna pass me without now that it's
looking that it's never gonna happen so
I'm suffering from success that's real
hard
1.3 million are you kidding me TV series
bye it's a trap the nine year old Army
has been tricked again before shaving I
have to shave who would have thought
Brad was a slob funny thing is Brad
where's that type of black cap all the
time as well if anyone can find him
wearing that cap you'll you'll see the
resemblance
I'm making a mod called PTA okay wait
boots left on a hook
that looks dope the music fits perfectly
it really similar to the beat I've never
hit me actually that's pretty dope
please let him see this took me a long
time I miss the old studio decoration
and sleepy yeah well do you not think I
miss my dead pet - thank you very much
for that by the way I am adding stuff I
literally haven't had no time to work on
the studio found a to kill a void while
looking through petabytes common replies
on the ears video PewDiePie damn ear
must be famous you better watch out
though if the media sees your coming
here they'll say you're not see god damn
it how did it why do you know what
Warren missed this could have been
avoided
shoutout to Brad for literally sitting
through footage of pills looking Hey
number 19 on gaming though huh who said
I wasn't a gamer who dare tell it if
anyone says I'm really not a gamer
anymore show him this that'll show him
do you smoke every time T series
overtakes me your long competition for
views to higher Slovak wieners Brad for
hire me as editor I mean they
practically look identical I don't think
anyone would notice a difference all
anyone ever wonder what is Brad's
reaction with editing I vote for Brad to
upload a video of him editing pewds
video see we thought about this that
kiss Brad streams online and then maybe
he could just stream himself editing the
problem is the problem is for some
people that I'm a you save some things
that don't actually make it to the final
cut and if those things end up in a live
stream then it's goodbye PewDiePie okay
Brad has been my filter for the last six
years you India you win but you swap you
little Ariana's reactions can take a
joke
I'm actually scared
Brad flashes text up on the screen too
fast for me to read me it's rude
we have a single mission we don't like
you teach series smash there subscribe
that's really dope
that's some high quality poster maybe
that could go in the background look at
that like that's like actually printable
Allen Portillo calm very cool is that
bread 1 and bread too ok let's do that's
really cool just drove past these kids
doing their part in the pouring rain I
went to the grocery store at an hour
later they're still out there with
getting some feelings I love the fact
that someone else posted this and not
themselves they're really just out there
I'm 9ag apologist and this is my third
time trying to upload this many hours oh
Jesus Christ
that is crazy
this is strangely hypnotizing and
arousing oh my god I can't stop looking
at it so weird the Queen the stream
Queen animation Queen slop cricket
coffee Shrek adidas adidas what the
Frick u-turn removes 58 million videos
featuring hateful and inappropriate
content no single video pits covered
there was thought of that that's
hilarious
I mean customers and welcome to bunnies
Wollongong as the time is now two
minutes past 7:00 this store has
officially ceased trading for this
evening
could you please assist our team by
finalizing the purchases and making your
way to the registers at the front of the
store I'd like to take this opportunity
to thank you for shopping at running
Guangdong and a friendly reminder to
subscribe to PewDiePie yes spike from
t-series just like you 231 plant more
trees save the bees
clean the Seas and I'll see you all
tomorrow morning at 7 a.m.
wait well is the shop Bunnings rare
house is doing their part thank you very
much oh my god fan art correction god
dammit can I not have one nice picture
do you really have to do you have to do
this every single goddamn time new subs
getting angry about Puetz call it being
: I see me first time really well saw
this isn't colombo sri lanka please
series how does this keep happening
who's doing this it's from this guy
that's might not realize the game is the
biggest YouTube channel in the world
Thank You Minya very cool okay I
performed with sivanna
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh that genuinely made me have a that's
so funny alright guys we're gonna have
to end that episode there thank you so
much for all the love and support the
Lola why why the merchant link in
description bye
[Music]
[Applause]